hi jason okay first of all what the hell
is in your bag
that's what i want to know my phone's
something very special and uh
i want to see it my lips are trapped
show us the bag
it's so snazzy
period period okay so helen mirren since
you're the most beautiful person on the
planet
are you going to share scenes with her
in fast x
i
sadly
i wish i was she's wonderful
um
sadly i'm not a very very very bad guy
and if i was in contact with her i
probably have to do something bad which
i don't want to because she's one of
them
in this obviously will do anything for
his family
i can tell you're the same way how do
you relate to that character when it
comes to your family too much
too much
it was a very challenging couple years
for me and i shot those while i was away
from my family
in canada back to back shooting season
two and season three so it was uh i'm
excited for everyone to see this it's
got a lot of weight in it
thank you enjoy your your handbag
it's a clutch baby
you